the movie is set in the year 1945 it
revolves around a woman named Grace
Stewart who lives in a large creepy
house in the balewhack of Jersey with
her two children Anne and Nicholas it's
winter and the world war has already
ended but Grace's husband who is
fighting in France hasn't returned home
yet Grace has hired servants to look
after the house and her children but two
weeks ago all of them mysteriously left
their jobs without notice one day three
people Mrs Bertha Mills Mr Tuttle and a
mute girl named Lydia show up at the
house and Grace immediately suspects
that they are here in response to an ad
that she had posted for new servants and
since Grace is in desperate need of them
she quickly welcomes the trio inside and
gives them a tour of the house she also
explains the strange rules that she has
implemented there one must never open a
door without closing the previous one
and the curtains must always remain
closed this is because both of her
children are photosensitive they break
out in rashes and sores if they are
exposed to even a small amount of
sunlight Grace further explains that the
house doesn't have a telephone or radio
because she prizes silence moreover
there isn't any electricity because they
are used to living without it these
people are vampires the servants are
weirded out by the strange rules but
nonetheless they agree to them and start
working Mrs Bertha takes the role of the
senior servant and serves the children
breakfast as they eat the little girl
Anne asks Mrs Bertha if she too would
abandon them like the other servants did
this puzzles Mrs Bertha and Dan reveals
that their previous servants left the
day grace went mad worried about their
family secret getting exposed Nicholas
yells at his sister to shut up it is
clear that something bad went down on
that fateful day when the two start to
squabble the noise attracts the
attention of Grace and she orders the
children to finish their breakfast
quietly Grace then takes Mrs Bertha to
another room and confronts her for
pretending to be a prospective servant
it turns out Grace found out that the
advertisement she had sent to a local
newspaper seeking servants was never
published Mrs Bertha apologizes to Grace
for keeping them in the dark and reveals
that some years back she missed Tuttle
and Lydia used to work as servants in
this very house they had grown so
attached to the house that they have
come back looking for work here Mrs
Bertha further claims that she was sure
that a large house like this one would
always need extra help when Grace
welcomed them thinking they had answered
the ad Mrs Bertha just did not want to
tell her otherwise hearing all this
Grace changes her mind and decides to
let the three continue working for her
despite the fact that this is all suss
is All Balls she then asks Mrs Bertha if
she's aware about the strange things
that happen around the house it turns
out that sometimes people can be heard
talking whispering and crying around the
house Mrs Bertha confirms she is aware
of the strange occurrences however Grace
tells her that she doesn't believe in
ghosts and warns Mrs Bertha against
affirming the children's beliefs that
there are ghosts in the house here we
get to know that Anna Nicholas have
reported to have heard and seen ghosts
around the house but Grace refuses to
believe them later that day grace asks
Mrs Bertha about Lydia's muteness but
for some reason the old woman avoids
talking about it after Mrs Bertha leaves
the room Grace hears Anne crying in the
other room worried she rushes to her
side but the girl tells her that she
wasn't crying in fact it was the little
ghost Victor making the noises and
claims that Victor was crying because he
doesn't like living in this house and
his pianist father doesn't let him leave
however once again Grace doesn't believe
in the story and scolds her daughter for
spreading lies the day becomes night and
Anne retires to bed with her little
brother it's revealed that Nicholas is
afraid of ghosts and he refuses to
believe that Victor exists to prove him
wrong Anne urges Victor to appear and
confirm his presence when the ghost boy
obliges and appears Nicholas freaks out
he screams for help prompting Grace to
rush to their room enraged she
immediately punishes her daughter for
feeding ideas into her brother's mind
and accepts her punishment of memorizing
the Bible but refuses to deny that
Victor and other ghosts exist one day
grace hears someone running upstairs
when she goes to inspect she asks Anne
about the noise but the latter denies
hearing anything Grace then presses her
daughter for the truth prom promising to
not punish her it turns out Grace is fed
up with denying the truth and wants to
get to the bottom of the strange
occurrences around the house and finally
admits that there's someone in the
nearby room when she goes to inspect
Grace sees an invisible figure leaving
the room opening and closing the door
behind them terrified she rushes out and
asks Anne about them the little girl
reveals that the ghosts claim to own the
house and they are now planning to
reclaim it Grace begins to panic and she
discusses the incident with Mrs Bertha
the old lady calms her down and Dan
shows her a picture of the Ghost Family
that allegedly lives in the house it
turns out Victor lives with his father
mother and an old woman in the house and
claims that she has seen the old female
ghost the most hearing all this Grace
finally believes her children and she
calls all the servants and carries out a
ghost hunt bust out the peanut butter
boys we're catching Casper tonight she
orders them to open all the curtains so
there aren't any dark Corners where
someone could hide however they fail to
locate anyone instead Grace comes across
pictures of the previous owners of the
house she also finds a photo album and
strangely in all the pictures the people
photographed are sleeping Grace asks Mrs
Bertha about the strange album and the
old woman reveals that the people in the
photographs aren't sleeping they are
actually dead it's the Book of the Dead
in the last century people used to take
photographs of the dad in the hopes that
their souls would go on living through
the portraits Grace is shocked by the
tradition and Mrs Bertha comments that
grief over the death of a loved one can
lead people to do the strangest things
as expected Grace is weirded out by the
books so she orders Mrs Bertha to
destroy them later that night she sits
down with Mrs Bertha and talks to her
about the previous owners of the house
who apparently moved to London Grace
again asks her about Lydia's muteness
and the old woman claims that the little
girl stopped talking one day for no
reason however Grace Finds the story
hard to believe as she feels like Lydia
must have gone through some sort of
trauma for her to suddenly stop talking
that night Grace wakes up to the sound
of someone playing the piano must be the
penis father or oh the piano dentist
pianist father that makes more sense
when she walks over to that room she
again Witnesses the presence of an
invisible being and gets frightened the
next day grace discusses it with Mrs
Bertha and the latter mentions that she
believes her she tells Grace that
sometimes the world of the living gets
mixed up with the world of the Dead this
is why they are constantly being visited
by the dead Souls who are apparently the
previous owners of the house as expected
the Revelation terrorizes Grace and she
decides to get her house blessed by a
priest but before leaving to find father
McGraw she orders Mr Tuttle to look for
gravestones on the property it turns out
Grace was told about a small Cemetery
inside the property when her husband
bought the house she suspects that the
previous owners of the house were buried
inside the property after Grace leaves
Mrs Bertha and Mr Tuttle discuss the
former's departure surprisingly two
alleged servants are hiding secrets of
their own and they are aware about the
hidden Graves on the property meanwhile
Grace gets lost in the mist and instead
of finding the priest she finds her
husband Charles she is shocked and also
relieved to find him alive and well for
some reason Charles looks lost and very
out of it but Grace brushes this aside
and brings him back home the children
are also delighted to finally have their
father back and they welcome him with a
warm embrace however much doesn't change
after his return as he spends most of
his time lying down on the bed hardly
interacting with his family moreover
after her husband's return Grace again
goes back to denying the existence of
ghosts much to Anne's dismay the scene
then cuts to the day of Anne's communion
Grace leaves her daughter for a moment
and heads to another room but when she
comes back she is horrified to find her
sitting on the dirty floor in her
communion dress moreover the little girl
is aged to become a creepy old woman
puzzled and Afraid Grace chokes the old
woman demanding to know where Anne is
eventually the veil rips off and Grace
learns that the person in the dress has
again turned to her daughter Anne
horrified by what just happened and runs
away accusing her mother of trying to
kill her grace is also equally
shell-shocked by the incident but she
doesn't know how to react later that day
Charlie strangely confronts her about
something that happened a week ago it
turns out that he is talking about the
same incident where Grace went mad
appearing remorseful she breaks down and
insists that it wasn't her fault she
doesn't know what took over her that day
however Charles doesn't believe her and
insists that he has to return to the war
Grace is naturally against this and she
reminds him that the war is over soon
the two get into an argument but one
thing leads to another and they start to
make love the next day grace wakes up to
find that Charles has laughed again as
she despairs over his departure Anna
Nicholas wake up to find the curtains in
their room gone when they start
screaming Grace quickly rushes to their
side she tries to take them to a dark
room only to realize that all curtains
from the entire property have been
removed left with no choice Grace blocks
the light from the window with a
chalkboard but surprisingly despite them
coming in direct contact with sunlight
the children don't break out in rashes
and sores instead they demand to see
their father but with a sad look Grace
reveals that he has left again she then
confronts the servants demanding to know
where the curtains went however they
appear to be nonchalant and suggest that
Anna Nicholas are no longer allergic to
sunlight this infuriates grace and she
orders them to leave the house
afterwards the children nervously hear
their mother turning the house upside
down looking for the curtains afraid
that she has gone mad again they decide
to sneak out of the house in search of
their father Grace eventually makes her
way to the servants rooms there she
finds a photograph of Mr Tuttle Lydia
and Mrs Mills inscribed 1891 from The
Book of the Dead this reveals that the
three are also ghosts who had died over
50 years ago on the other hand Ann and
Nicholas come across the gravestones of
the same three servants surprisingly the
trio appears in the distance and starts
approaching and Nicholas afraid the
children run back into the house with
the servants following they reunite with
Grace and she immediately jumps in to
protect them from the approaching ghosts
she tries to shoot them but as expected
the bullets have no effect on the ghosts
however Grace locks them out and tells
her children to hide from outside the
door Mrs Bertha tells Grace that she
must learn to live with the dad in the
same house she claims that she and her
friends died long ago when they
contracted tuberculosis and just like
Grace they were unaware about it for a
few months and kept living in the house
as if nothing had happened but one day
they eventually got to know the truth
and that is when Lydia went into shock
and became mute Mrs Bertha continues
that even if she and her friends leave
the other ghosts will never leave the
house and they will eventually find Anne
and Nicholas soon enough the old ghost
lady from earlier in the movie finds the
children who yell for their mother Grace
rushes upstairs and there she notices
the old lady and Victor's family sitting
around a table it's clear that they are
performing a seance to speak to Grace
and the children the old woman is acting
as the speaker here in a shocking turn
of events it is revealed that Grace and
her children are the actual ghosts
moreover the woman and the other people
sitting at the table are normal humans
who have been tormented by the Dead's
presence Grace and children are already
dead but they are unaware of it and
continue living as if everything is
normal the old woman tells the children
that they are dead and asks them about
what happened on the day they were
killed Grace panics and tries to stop
the Seance when nothing works she grabs
the medium paper and tears it apart
eventually managing to break the Seance
later Grace finally comes to terms with
the situation and reveals about the day
that she went mad her husband Charles
hadn't returned from the war and this
caused her to spiral into depression and
on that fateful day she couldn't bear
the pain anymore and killed her children
by suffocating them after this she
committed the unthinkable this was the
reason why the servants left the house
unexpectedly moreover it is also
revealed that Charles who returned to
the house was also a ghost as he had
already died in the war the house is
currently inhabited by The Pianist his
wife and son Victor they are scared to
death because of the hauntings of Grace
and her children the movie ends with
Victor and his family leaving the house
as Grace watches from upstairs the house
is again put up for for sale but Grace
and her children vowed to never leave
the place as they belong here subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching